first of all i just want to say you and
your boyfriend do the cutest tick tocks
ever they're super adorable which one of
you do you think has mastered tick tock
more
i mean he has a tick tock account i
don't have a tick tock account
so he just in general knows how to use
it and i don't
um so i would say him but i but let's
listen here i've come up with some good
ideas
okay you just give him all the credit
that's a very nice girlfriend
the cutting and the pasting all the
stuff that it's very hard for me
it's true it is a lot um
you know the fans are just so excited to
see what happens in season three however
in in the third film how everything
wraps up do you think that this is the
ending of this love story that fans
deserve
i do i do i do i really do
um i think that even though they might
not physically be together i think it's
so important to
show the fans of the film
that you need to go and do what's right
for you
and make choices that's right for you um
and even if they're not physically
together
if you love someone and if they love you
you will know and you have to trust them
and it can work
um and so you know i think it's probably
pretty bummer that they don't get to
like have sleepovers or whatever in
college and like be cute to college
together
but i think that i think it's satisfying
i think people
love i think they i think they want to
see lara jean
step into the world on her own
um i completely agree no so i'm not i'm
happy with it
i am too i loved it so much it was
everything i wanted for
you know some of my favorite characters
and storylines and how it wrapped up
you and noah have just such fantastic
chemistry it continued throughout all
three films
what are you gonna miss the most about
working with him i'm so happy
that it continues throughout all three
films imagine it would have been such a
nightmare if it happened
that would have sucked keep it alive
keep it live keep in mind
no it was great i actually think i
enjoyed you both the most in this film
isn't that crazy
that's crazy but i get that because it
also shows i think in this i think
what's so exciting about this
the um always in forever is that
you can tell how comfortable they are
together yeah
you know and i think it's very um
reminiscent to how comfortable noah and
i
are together and we've spent years
together now working so
um i think that the
i think the thing that i'll miss the
most about
working with noah is
i think he's just a really good listener
i think he's a great listener
um he make in life
but also in scenes um
i think i don't think a lot of people
know that he
he really sits and he's very emotional
and he will listen to what you have to
say sit with it
and like weigh it emotionally before he
answers
um and i really appreciate that
as a like just a human being and also as
an actor
um so yeah i'll definitely miss that and
he was the best
scene partner i could have had seriously
i could never even imagine like
anyone else playing his character oh i
love that so much and wrapping things up
any valentine's day plans
i mean because we're in a pandemic it's
like
what really can we do but i think i'll
probably watch the film
um with anthony
and just cry
[Laughter]
that sounds like a good plan
i love it thank you so much and congrats
on everything that's awesome thank you
so much